I've moved on I'm sure Taylor's moved on
and it feels nice and we're all friends
it's it's all good
that's Joe Jonas on ITV's Lorraine
speaking out about his relationship with
Taylor Swift after her recent appearance
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show what is the
most rebellious and rebellious thing you
did as a teenager probably when I like
put Joe Jonas on blast on your show that
was too much we laugh about it now
that's good that was yeah Alfie yeah
yeah just all right teenage stuff there
in case you need a refresher here's the
moment Taylor was referencing from 2008
that guy's not in my life anymore
unfortunately I know that's not I'm
sorry that guy that's out it's all right
I'm cool you know what it's like it's
like when I find that person that that
is is right for me I'm not even gonna be
able to remember the boy who broke up
with me over the phone in 25 seconds
when I was eight yeah were you glad to
receive that public apology ten years
old yeah I mean it did feel nice it's
something that I probably was feeling
pretty bad about when I was younger
Taylor and Joe dated pretty briefly for
just three months back in 2008 but a
three-month romance is pretty long when
you're 18 long enough to inspire a few
of Taylor's songs over the years
including forever in all ways
[Music]
being intuitive Taylor and Joe are both
now 29 and in love with other people
Taylor has been quietly dating actor Joe
Alwyn for nearly three years while Joe
recently tied the knot with Game of
Thrones star sophie Turner
[Music]